nicholas sarkozy was not in the paris
court for the verdict into the so-called
magmalian corruption trial but his 13
co-accused were all were found guilty of
illegal campaign financing sarkozy was
sentenced to a year under house arrest
president sarkozy with whom i spoke on
the phone just now asked me to go and
appeal which i will do immediately when
i leave here and of course the judgment
will not be enforceable
nicholas sarkozy failed to be re-elected
as french president in 2012 despite a
lavish campaign the scale of his rallies
was designed to impress but instead it
set off alarm bells
a police investigation accused sarkozy
and his campaign team of spending more
than double the 27 million legal limit
set by the french state and hiring a pr
company called big malian to help cover
up the overspending with a system of
fake invoices
during the trial sarkozy denied any
wrongdoing but the judge in her verdict
said that sarkozy knew how much could be
spent on a presidential campaign because
he'd run before and he knew the law she
also said that he had twice received
written warnings about the risks of
overspending
symbolically it's important to say that
a president
doesn't get any immunity
and has to respond to the law
it is also important because the
campaign
for 2022 is coming so we have to have
this reflection about
how to prevent illegal financing of a
political campaign
sarkozy served one term as president
from 2007 a straight talker with a love
of luxury he was tough on immigration
and crime he retired from politics in
2017. in recent years the political
right wing has struggled in france but
sarkozy's remained prominent for a lot
of french citizens who
vote for the right side nikola sagosi is
seen as this kind of
all-time somehow reassuring figure
the conviction is a further blow to
sarkozy's reputation in march he was
found guilty of corruption in a
different case and he could soon be back
in court he's accused of receiving
illegal campaign funds from the late
libyan leader muhammad gaddafi sarkozy's
legal problems it seems are far from
over natasha butler al jazeera paris